[Music]
you see the reason you want to be better
is the reason why you aren't
we aren't better because we want to be
because the road to hell is paved with
good intentions
because all the do-gooders in the world
whether they're doing good for others or
doing it for themselves are
troublemakers
on the basis of kindly let me help you
or you'll drown
said the monkey putting the fish safely
up a tree
we white anglo-saxon protestants british
german
american have
been on a rampage for the past hundred
or more years
to improve the world
we have given the benefits of our
culture our religion our technology to
everybody
except perhaps the australian aborigines
and we have insisted that they receive
the benefits of our culture
even our political styles our democracy
you better be democratic or we'll shoot
you
[Music]
and having conferred these blessings all
over the place we wonder why everybody
hates us
see because sometimes doing good to
others
and even doing good to oneself is
amazingly destructive
[Music]
because it's full of conceit how do you
know what's good for other people
how do you know what's good for you if
you say
uh you want to improve
then you want to know what's good for
you but obviously you
don't because if you did you would be
improved
so we don't know it's like the problem
of geneticists
which they face today i went to a
meeting of geneticists not so long ago
where they gathered in a group of
philosophers and theologians and said
now look here
we need help we now are on the verge of
figuring out
how to breed any kind of human character
we would want to have we can give you
saints
philosophers scientists great
politicians anything you want just tell
us
what kind of human beings are we to
breed
so i said how will
those of us who are genetically
unregenerate
make up our minds what genetically
generate people might be
because i'm afraid very much that our
selection of virtues
may not work it may be like
for example this new kind of
yield grain which is made
and uh which is becoming ecologically
destructive
when we interfere with the processes of
nature and breed
efficient plants and deficient animals
there's always some way in which we have
to pay for it
and i can well see that eugenically
produced human beings
might be dreadful
we could have a plague of virtuous
people
do you realize that any animal
considered in itself is virtuous
it does its thing but in crowds they're
awful
like a crowd of ants or locusts on the
rampage
they're all perfectly good animals but
it's just too much
i could imagine a perfectly pesticide
mass of a million saints
so i said to these people look was the
only thing you can do
just be sure that a vast
variety of human beings is maintained
don't please breed us down to a few
excellent types
excellent for what we never know how
circumstances are going to change
and how our need
for different kinds of people changes
at one time we may need very
individualistic and aggressive people
at another time we may need very
cooperative
teamworking people at another time we
may need people who are full of interest
in
dexterous manipulation of the external
world at another time we may need people
who explore into their own psychology
and are introspective
there is no knowing but the more
varieties and the more skills we have
obviously the better
so you see here again the problem comes
out in genetics
we do not really know how to interfere
with the way the world is
the way the world actually is
is an enormously complex interrelated
organism
the same problem arises in medicine
because the body
is a very complexly interrelated
organism
and if you look at the body in a
superficial way you may see that
something wrong with it
is chickenpox and there's spots that
itch that come all
out all over the place well you might
say well
spots are there cut them off
so you kill the bug well then you find
you've got real problems
because you have to introduce some bugs
to kill the bug it's like bringing
rabbits into australia
and that starts going all over the place
and getting out of hand
but then you think well now wait a
minute it wasn't the bugs in the blood
there are bugs all over the place
what was wrong with this person that his
blood system
suddenly became vulnerable to those
particular bugs
his resistance wasn't up therefore what
you should have given was not an
antibiotic but vitamins
okay so we're going to build up his
resistance but resistance to what
you may build up resistance to this and
this and this class of bugs but then
there's another one that loves that
situation and comes right in
see we always look at the human being
medically in bits and pieces
because we have heart specialists lung
specialists
bone specialists nerve specialists and
so on
and they each see the human being from
their point of view
there are a few generalists but they
realize the human body is so complicated
that no one mind can understand it
and furthermore supposing we do succeed
in healing all these people of their
diseases
what do we then do about the population
problem
i mean we've stopped cholera the black
bubonic plague
we're getting the better of tuberculosis
we may fix cancer and heart disease
then what will people die of well there
let's go on living
will be enormous quantities of us then
we have to fix this birth thing
pills for everybody then we find what
are the effects the side effects of
those pills
what are the psychological effects upon
men and women of not breeding
children in the usual way
we don't know
and what seems a good thing today or
yesterday like ddt
turns out tomorrow to have been a
disaster
what seemed in the moral and spiritual
sphere too
like great virtues in times past
are easily seen today as hideous evils
let's take for example the inquisition
in its own day among catholics
the holy inquisition was regarded
as we today regard the practice of
psychiatry
you you see you you feel that incurring
a person of cancer
almost anything is justified the most
complex operation is the most
weird surgery people suspended for days
and days on end on the end of tubes
[Music]
with x-ray penetration burning
or people undergoing shock treatment
people locked
in the colorless monotonous corridors of
mental institutions
in all good faith they knew that
witchcraft and heresy
were terrible things
awful plagues imperiling people's souls
forever and ever
so any means were justified to cure
people
of heresy
we don't change we're doing the same
thing today
but under different names
we can look back at those people and see
how evil that was
but we can't see it in ourselves
so therefore beware a virtue
laotzer the chinese philosopher said the
highest
virtue is not virtue
and therefore really is virtue
but inferior virtue cannot let go of
being virtuous
and therefore is not virtue
translated in more of a periphrastic way
the highest virtue is not conscious of
itself as virtue
and therefore really is virtue lower
virtue
is so self-conscious that it's not
virtue
in other words when you breathe
you don't congratulate yourself on being
virtuous
but breathing is a great virtue it's
living
when you come out with beautiful eyes
blue or brown or green as the case may
be
you don't congratulate yourself for
having grown one of the most
fabulous jewels on earth
it's just eyes and you don't account it
to virtue
to see to entertain the miracles of
color and form
you say oh that's just
but that's real virtue virtue in the
sense of the old sense of the word a
strength
is when we talk about the healing virtue
of a plant
that's real virtue
but the other virtues are stuck on their
air signs
they're imitation virtues
and they usually create trouble
because more diabolical things are done
in the name of righteousness and be
assured that everybody
of whatever nationality or political
frame of mind
or religion always goes to war
with a sense of complete rightness
the other side is the devil
[Music]
our opponents whether in
china or russia or vietnam
have the same feeling of righteousness
about what they're doing as we have on
our side
and the plague on both houses
[Music]
because as confucius said
the goody goodies are the thieves of
virtue
which is the form of our own proverb the
road to hell
is paved with good intentions
[Music]
you